Iranian-backed paramilitary groups protesting against US air strikes in Iraq...
...began to withdraw from the US embassy in Baghdad even as Tehran and Washington traded threats.
In Hong Kong, police fired several rounds of tear gas at crowds during a New Year's Day march...
...that has drawn tens of thousands of people, including families with children.
In Australia, authorities confirmed a third death in devastating bushfires...
...that engulfed the country's southeast coastal region this week...
...and said a fourth person who has been missing is feared dead.
In Indonesia, at least nine people were killed in capital city Jakarta...
...as the worst flooding since 2013 inundated the city of 30 million people.
Finally from the Netherlands, thousands of Dutch swimmers...
...braved near-freezing temperatures to mark the start of the new year.